as politicians gather to Mark the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
I'm very pleased to say that we are
joined by lira's Sister Nicola to talk
about her life and Legacy good morning
Nicola
good morning Trevor
um lira is being awarded a posthumous
medal tomorrow can you tell us a bit
about that please
so um the chancellor of Queen's
University Belfast who has uh Hillary
Clinton she has
um
been asked to give Leah a medal a
Chancellor's medal and it's for
recognition for the Civic services that
and Lira was involved in during her
lifetime here and for the work that she
did
um to try to encourage peace and a
greater inclusion in our society
I understand this is uh not always the
easiest conversation for somebody in
your situation
um so please take your time
um
would you mind for those
viewers who are not completely familiar
with the story telling us what Lira was
doing and how she met her end
well Lira was an investigative
journalist she began
um her career in journalism when she was
very young when she was about 15 she was
involved in a children's charity called
children's Express
um where they work with young people
from all different backgrounds across
community and encourage them in the
fields of the media and it was
journalism that lira
found a love end and so she
wrote stories became excuse me Sky young
journalist of the year
and she was very interested in listening
to the real life stories of the of the
people around her the people in society
the people who weren't being heard and
weren't being listened to the Working
Class People
um victims of violence in our society
victims of suicide their families and
she was interested in looking at those
things but she was also interested in
looking at
um the division within our own country
and looking at how
um quite often the political
Representatives
are responsible for the continuance of
that division by stoking up sectarianism
and different things like that so she
was really trying to expose
um
what was really happening for people at
the time of
um her death she was investigating The
Disappearance of young boys who had gone
missing during the troubles here in
Northern Ireland and the police had
um obviously looked into it but had not
launched the investigation that perhaps
they would have launched had it not been
for the distraction of the troubles
which of course you you will know that
um people were being killed quite
frequently
um shot The rebalmings Happening Here
and so the resources within policing
were
um being targeted towards
trying to deal with with that violence
and there was very interested in the
story of these boys because she wanted
to be able to bring
their family's closure because they had
gone out to school in the morning and
didn't come home that evening no one
ever saw them again once they were at
the bus stop and and those boys and
other young people like that
have never ever been recovered and we
never hear those stories Lair was
interested in the stories that we never
get to hear about because nobody seems
to want to tell those stories and they
were the people that she was interested
in at the time of her
um murder
she
was
in Derry Londonderry she had just moved
there and obviously she was still a
journalist
and
as you can see from some footage from
the news at the time
that she was looking at the riot Through
The Eyes of a journalist
and
she
would have been probably very interested
in what would encourage young people to
become involved in that kind of violence
because she was so interested in and the
needs of the working class we're working
class people were brought up in working
class area I still live in the same
working class area not too far from
where Lara was born and she was
interested in the story of our people
because nobody was representing
um The Working Class People and she was
still doing it up until
um the day that she was killed
tragically
Nicola
um
you've described eloquently I think the
body of lira's working
that's partly why she became the young
journalist of the year and I think
everybody who's in who is in journalism
will understand
the quality of that work but she's also
in some way become
I think iconic for young people
particularly in Northern Ireland but
also I think actually in the island of
Ireland uh
what would you
think say she would be saying to a young
person who might be interested in
a career in journalism but who has seen
uh
if you like the ultimate downside of her
kind of desire to expose truth
and the danger that some journalists
encounter what would she say to a young
potential journalist now
well I think that she would say if you
love it then you must do it
um because I know that she loved it and
that was why she felt the need to do it
and I think that she would encourage
other young people still to become
involved and there is a bursary with the
center for investigative journalists and
the Leo McKee bursary and lots of young
disadvantaged people have
received training in journalism
um through that bursary and some of the
success stories emanating from that
bursary in Lara's name have been
phenomenal uh young people getting
stories published and picked up by big
media agencies and one of their
graduates from the scheme actually
and started their own news platform to
share the stories within their area so I
know that she would be absolutely behind
any young person that wanted to get into
journalism
um I know from our
um history here in Northern Ireland in
our life experience here is that someone
coming out onto a straight at a riot
with a gun is
it's almost
never happened almost never happened
should never have happened but it is a
very very
unusual thing to have happened I don't
think people appreciate how unusual that
was you know these kind of riots and
disturbances are quite commonplace at
different times of the year in our
country unfortunately but someone coming
out a gunman coming out onto the street
is a very unusual occurrence during a
riot of that nature
so I think that
um while Leia was very very mindful of
the risks that she took as a journalist
she still took those risks because she
still felt the need to tell other
people's stories and to enable their
voices to be heard through the work that
she did
Nicola um Sky will be following that
award tomorrow and I think everybody
watching and everybody here so I will be
with you in spirit on that in the hope
that um out of such an awful awful
moment something good will come as
you've just been describing uh Nicola
thank you so much indeed for joining us
thank you very much Trevor thanks for
inviting me have a lovely day